we are now really starting to get to
what is hopefully the
end game with the coronavirus pandemic
as many of you know a couple of weeks
ago the cdc as well as
joe biden in support of the cdc remember
joe biden doesn't come up with this
stuff on his own he just goes by what
the cdc says announcing that
outside masking can be dramatically
reduced
for vaccinated people in almost every
situation other than very large crowds
gathering mass together outdoors
over the weekend dr anthony fauci now
signaled
what is really a major major step
in getting to the end of this thing dr
fauci said yesterday
that indeed he is open to starting to
reduce
indoor masking rules we know uh
999 out of a thousand cases
prior to vaccination were being
transmitted indoors
uh and that we are getting to a level in
the vaccination campaign
now with 34 percent of the country fully
vaccinating
at vaccinated adding nearly one percent
to that every single day
um dr fauci saying that indeed we quote
do
need to start being more liberal in
terms of rules for wearing masks
indoors but just not quite yet not
quite yet we're down to about 43 000
cases a day
the lowest it's been for a very long
time but at the same time
not quite there yet but very soon
um dr fauci saying it may be time
to look at easing some indoor masking
guidelines and that really will be
a sign that we are very close to the end
of this thing bearing in mind of course
that individuals who remain at higher
risk are going to likely want to take
more precautions bearing in mind that in
the fall or winter it may be time for a
booster vaccine
tweak tailored and calibrated towards
the main variants that
the primary variants that have emerged
over the last several months
friday the cdc updated its guidance
about how the virus
spreads saying people could inhale
airborne virus even from more than six
feet away
from an infected individual this is
something that had been widely reported
by
other agencies and researchers the cdc
now saying it plainly
so in particular when it comes to indoor
this is where the overwhelming majority
of the contagion is happening
that being said it's dr fauci
as well as the former head of the fda dr
scott gottlieb all
saying we are very close
to statistically being able to ease off
of these indoor masking requirements
quote especially if you're in
environments where you know
you have a high level of vaccination and
that it would
also give public uh health officials
more credibility to reinstate
more guidelines if there is a surge in
the fall
that is problematic and doesn't uh isn't
well dealt with quickly enough
by the booster shots and i think that
that's an important point
both of them saying there's a degree of
fatigue
for lack of a better term with a lot of
these guidelines
and when the the data
justify easing those
if we need to put them back in in four
months six months eight months or
whenever
we hopefully will have more people
listen to us now i know that that
there are parts of the country where
nobody's going to listen and nobody's
been doing this stuff
to begin with but for those who have
been following cdc guidelines like me
hearing very concrete statements like
you really don't need to wear a mask
outside now that you're vaccinated david
unless you're
together with a crowd of people uh that
is great that is a great
relief and that also provides an
opportunity
to have a period of time if indeed
things are going to get worse
uh where we can feel better about what's
going on i actually think that
from all the evidence we're seeing dr
eric topple recently tweeting
very good data about the vaccines well
handling the british variant the
brazilian
the south african the new york the
indian and the california variants
so if we can keep vaccinating hopefully
all of this will not
come to pass now there are people
who are not going to be coming out of
this they're just they're remaining
home and masked um for the foreseeable
future
even as the guidelines are going to ease
and i think that
that's fine uh some people may do it
because of medical conditions others
because of a sort of pandemic induced
agoraphobia
this is going to be a real issue and
it's going to be an issue for some
period of time i think the point is
no one's going to be banned from taking
any precaution
they want to take but the numbers i mean
in some states you are seeing
a number of deaths which is the same as
what you would see during
uh during flu in other words there's
states where over the course of a year
five people a day die of flu during a
normal flu season
and some of those states are now seeing
five to seven coronavirus deaths per day
once it gets down to that point it
really
becomes more of an individual risk
assessment
than statewide or federal guidelines or
mandates
and that is going to be the direction
things are shifting and i think it's
perfectly fine
for people to make those risk
assessments for themselves
but when you start hearing dr fauci
saying we are soon going to be
liberalizing
indoor mass guidelines when you hear dr
scott gottlieb say it
you know that you are getting to sort of
one of the last considerations
we just have to keep vaccinating if you
are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video